you want to talk about the time you
worked out with all its warts and Egger
that's a really good story I've heard
about it yeah it was it was epic um we
were just a cool guy he's the best yeah
we're so stoked to meet someone as
stoked on civil service as we are but he
goes to like he conquers everything
right yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
we went to his office and it's like it's
the coolest place I've ever seen he's
from Austria and yeah he came over to
this country and he conquered the whole
country yeah yeah like entertainment
sports politics Arnold
yeah great call yeah it's a great yeah
so what I wouldn't know what we know
about bicep development right you guys
are in pretty good shape what did he
teach you well with him I just focused
on calf raises because that's Laramie he
was known for that when he was about a
professional building a gigantic cow
yeah and I was like Arnold I need good
calves because I think that's just the
benchmark for it
and not at the start he had small calves
to start so he cut the bottom sleeves
off of all of his pants so that his
small calves would be exposed so he
could see them and humiliate them and to
get yeah and motivate himself to make
him bigger no [ __ ] yeah he told you that
no oh you just know that yes and then
when you worked out with him did he talk
to you or was he just like quiet he's
serious about the weights you know he
doesn't want to talk while we lift him
but we chatted with him in between
sessions so meeting Arnold
Schwarzenegger in a way it sounds I mean
you know you know it sounds like you
worked out with him mm-hmm
he helped you with your calves and then
that was it did you ever hear from him
again
we went to his a contest on the Santa
Monica Pier yeah and we he brought us
onstage and we did deadlifts in front of
everyone it was like huge because I
never deadlift and he's like put up to
fit I can't do that accident put dr.
cool 50 right now yeah and I freaking
did it yeah he was there yeah JT put it
up to you 50 good technique yeah yeah
Wow yeah he tossed technique to why you
guys are awesome